الصوره الجامعه
فعلامه اجتمعت كلمه اسيان وشركائها في
كمبوديا
طفحت الاجتماعات باحاديث عن الشركات
الاستراتيجيه لكن المقاربات والرؤى قل ان
تتقاطع وبين الحضور قوان لها مصالح
متعارضه
تسمع من الامريكيين التزاما بمنطقه
المحيطين الهندي مع وجود اسيان في مركز
الاهتمام ولا تقل عن ذلك اهميه في الفهم
الامريكي مساله الحفاظ على السلام
والاستقرار عبر مضيقي
احترام حريه الملاحه والتحليق في البحرين
شرقي وجنوب الصين وضروره حل كل النزاعات
السلميه
الى تحديد الخطوط الحمر في العلاقات مع
الصين مع ابقاء خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه بين
الجانبين هذه سامحه ايضا للتاكيد على
تحالفات واشنطن الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه حلفان اساسيان
للولايات المتحده وقد انخرطت بلداننا منذ
سنوات في تعاون ثلاثي بدافع القلق المشترك
بشان تهديدات الصواريخ النوويه التي
تشكلها كوريا الشماليه على شعوبنا هذا
التعاون مهم اكثر من اي وقت مضى طالما
تواصل كوريا الشماليه سلوكها لاستفزازي
ذاك سلوك يتوقع رئيس وزراء اليابان فهم
يوك شده مزيدا منه مما يحرك ورغبه بلاده
في دعم اكبر للتعاون مع الولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه انه تعاون ثلاثي يراه
الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي يونسكو يول حسنا
قويا لحمايه القيم العالميه والحفاظ على
السلام والاستقرار في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
وشمال شرقي اسيا
الهم الراهن الاخر اوكرانيا لم يغب عن
النقاشات في كمبوديا اثار الامريكيون هناك
مساله تعزيز الدعم المنسقي لاوكرانيا في
الحرب مع روسيا وما كانت تلك النبرا لتروق
للروس
لم تتخذ اي قرارات جماعيه اليوم عقب اسرار
الولايات المتحده وشركائها الغربيين على
لهجه غير مقبوله على الاطلاق فيما يتعلق
بالوضع في اوكرانيا وهذا ما تسبب في عدم
اصدار بيان مشترك بشان اجتماعات القمه لو
كان الهدف زرع الشك في رابطه اسيان وتقويض
تجانسها بشكل عام نجح الامريكيون في تحقيق
اهدافهم من اهدافه واشنطن الاخرى
في اوكرانيا باغراء اليابان وكندا
ونيوزيلندا بالانضمام اليه
وعلى جبهه اخرى يعتقد الروس بان
الامريكيين يسعون للسيطره عسكريا على اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ وتلك محاوله بدل انها تروم
تقويض واحتواء المصالح الروسيه والصينيه
في المنطقه